hey this is press tow Walker ABCD is a
square a point p is chosen uniformly at
random in the interior of the
square construct the angle
APD the question is what is the
probability that angle APD is greater
than
90° in other words what is the
probability that angle APD is an obtuse
angle I thank num for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
[Music]
problem I will first present a geometric
trick to solve the problem and then I
will illustrate the solution using
coordinate geometry this is the long way
but it's an extremely important method
to learn in case you didn't see the
trick so let's get started with the
geometric
trick construct a semicircle with
diameter a
d now suppose the point p is on the
circumference of the
semicircle then APD will be an inscribed
angle of the semicircle so it will be a
right angle so a1d is equal to
90° this also means the other two angles
of this triangle will sum up to 9 90° so
P1 a d plus P1 da is equal to
90° now let's consider P2 that's in the
exterior of the semicircle but in the
interior of the square now look at this
diagram
ap2d now P2 a d is greater than P1 a and
P2 da is greater than P1
da so the sum of these two angles will
be larger than
90° that means that a p2d must be less
than 90° because the sum of the three
angles in a triangle must be equal to
90° so in other words if we have a point
P2 that's in the exterior of the
semicircle but in the interior of the
square it will be an acute angle so we
just have one more case to consider
let's suppose a point P3 is in the
interior of the semicircle now construct
this triangle now P3 a d and P3 da are
smaller than the corresponding angles P1
a d and P1 da so the sum of these two
angles will be less than
90° since the three angles in a triangle
sum to 180° we can conclude that a p3d
is greater than
90° so what does that mean we need the
point to be in the interior of the
semicircle so the probability the angle
is greater than 90° is equal to the area
of the semicircle divided by the area of
the square now let's say the semicircle
has a radius that's equal to R so the
length of the square is equal to 2 R so
the area of the semicircle is p piun r 2
/ 2 the area of the square is equal to
the square of 2 R we simplify this to
get piun / 8 which is approximately
equal to
39.3% and that's one way to solve the
problem congratulations if you saw the
geometric trick and were able to solve
the problem in the fastest
way but what if you didn't see the trick
too often I hear a frustration from
students well mathematics is just a
bunch of tricks you either know the
method to solve the problem or you don't
know the method and there's nothing you
can
do I'm here to tell you don't give up
many problems can be approached from
multiple
angles if you don't see the clever trick
to solve the problem you might be able
to work out the problem in a longer way
while it might take more work it might
lead you to some interesting mathematics
and in the history of mathematics some
discoveries have been made because
people looked at a problem from a
different angle so in this ve I'm going
to present a solution with coordinate
geometry now perhaps 90% of people have
tuned out now because they solved the
problem they got the answer but this
method is useful because in case you
didn't see the geometric trick this will
give you an approach to solve these
problems and it'll show you some other
interesting mathematics so let's get
started we have our Square so let's set
up a coordinate system where side a d is
on the x axis and side AB is on the y
axis let's say the square has a side
length equal to one so that point D is
at 1 comma 0er we have a point p in the
interior and we'll label this as X comma
y so we construct the triangle
APD by Al kashi's law of cosin the
square of the length of a is equal to
the square of the length of AP plus the
square of the length of PD minus 2 * the
length of AP * the length of PD time the
cosine of the angle
APD we can rearrange this to solve for
the cosine of the angle and then we have
the square of AP plus the square of PD
minus the square of a all over 2 * the
length of AP * the length of
PD now if the angle is between 0° and
90° the cosine of the angle will be
positive if the angle is exactly equal
to 90° the cosine of the angle will be
equal to zero and if we have an obtuse
angle between 90° and 180° the cosine of
the angle will be less than
zero so let's look at this formula and
we want to figure out the sign whether
the coine of the angle is a positive
negative or equal to
zero now in the denominator we have 2 *
the length of AP time the length of PD
so this will be some positive number
greater than zero so this won't affect
the S of the cosine of the angle we know
this is greater than zero so we can just
focus on the
numerator so we want to see whether a^ 2
+ pd^ 2us a d^ 2 is less than zero
that'll be the condition for an obtuse
angle we can now calculate this using
the distance formula we have x^2 + y^2 +
the sare of 1 - x + y^2 - 1 is less than
0 we can expand the binomial and collect
like terms so we have 2x^2 - 2x + 2 y is
less than 0 we divide through by two so
we have x^2 - x + y^2 is less than Z so
where do we go from here well we use a
standard trick of completing the square
so we will add 1 over4 to both sides of
the equation so that we can Factor we
the square of x -2 + y^2 is less than
the square of 12 this exactly describes
the semicircle whose Center is halfway
along the side a d and has a radius
that's equal
to2 so the condition is the point P has
to be in the interior of this semicircle
so we figured out the geometric trick
using this analytic method of coordinate
geometry so now once again the
probability the angle is obtuse is equal
to the area of the semicircle divided by
the area the square this will be < * 5^
2 / 2 all over 1 and this works out to
be < / 8 which is approximately equal to
39.3% and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time